hey folks welcome to my weird background
commanders deck building challenge two
weeks ago I gave the following prompt to
my Discord server build a deck using one
of the choos a background commanders you
see on screen now partnered with a
background of the person's choosing
there were a lot of decks this time
around doing a first pass through by
myself worked fine last time so I
figured I'd do that again this time and
uh it it took a while it's fine I had a
lovely time looking through 400 decks
the judging criteria were creativity
cohesion and likelihood to produce
dynamic gameplay the first two were the
main two I wanted to see Decks that were
cool interesting and unique in some way
and I wanted to see decks where the
command Zone and all other major
elements of the deck felt cohesively
tied together into a unified and
functioning package there's nothing
majorly wrong with a cohesive deck
that's a little Bland or a funky deck
that's a little all over the place but
in this challenge I was looking for the
Confluence between these two features
after I had done the first pass through
on the decks I discussed the ones that
stood out with me the most with my
co-host on the magic mirror podcast 33
elk and my IRL friend Hans and picked
out a winner for each of the five
commanders based on their input so this
video will be showcasing those decks and
touching briefly on honorable mentions
for each Commander as well those
honorable mentions will be featured in
their own tab on my website Linked In
the description also I'll be showing
some fun charts for these commanders as
well compiled by people in my Discord
server shout outs to Jack and a garbage
bag of human teeth for going to the
effort of putting that together without
further ado the first Commander option
was allora merry Thief a three Mana 32
with the text whenever you attack up to
one target attacking creature can't be
blocked this turn return that creature
to its owner's hand at the beginning of
the next end step this is an interesting
card because bouncing a creature at end
of turn is generally a significant
downside for most decks and not worth
the benefit of giving that creature
unblockable this Commander had the most
submissions at around 100 and people
tackled this in a variety of different
ways some used ball lightning style
cards that would otherwise sack an end
of turn some used ninjas a lot used
allora as a way to recycle etbs some
were initiative decks and a couple
paired allora with cultist of the
absolute and some haste equipments in
order to avoid needing to sacrifice a
creature on upkeep as you can see on
this plot is it allur de were the most
popular with deir Laura following
closely behind for a few honorable
mentions we have a deck based around the
card Dawn of the Dead a deck that
focuses on the card ether Ral as a way
to help with getting creatures back into
play and a spell lless Spell slinger
deck that one is a funny one and it was
a favorite among people on my Discord
server for the winning deck though we
have a returning winner filthy Stacks
player submitted a sneak attack deck
with Guild Artisan chosen as the
partnered background now the choice to
run sneak attack wasn't a unique one for
this challenge getting creatures out at
a discount to be sacrificed at end of
turn makes sense as a way to utilize Aur
and was a reasonably popular choice as a
result however this deck had a handful
of construction choices that made it
stand out Above the Rest of the crowd
for one it's utilization of its
background Guild Artis wasn't a wildly
popular background in the challenge but
it could be a nice treasure engine more
importantly though this deck pairs it
with polymorph effects that's right this
deck can tutor out a sneak attack effect
via one of two cards that remove a
permanent to grab one of the same type
doing so by polymorphing its own
background which is conveniently
castable from the command Zone this can
also work with the treasures produced by
Guild Artisan to polymorph for artifacts
since chaotic transformation can Target
multiple permanent types and reality
scramble can be cast multiple times via
every Trace these are supplemented with
a handful of tutors that com find
instance and sorceries enabling the deck
to have consistent access to its key
enchantments one natural question for a
sneak attack deck is what is being snuck
out in this case there's a total of 16
creatures of Mana value six or greater a
pretty robust number among these some
number are your typical cheat deck
beaters such as ancient stone idle and
cityscape leveler but past these there
are some more interesting ones balefire
Dragon provides a source of large scale
removal n spine dragon can allow for
some big draw with creative turn
ordering and there are also a number of
ETB creatures that can get value turn
over turn utilizing sneak attack and
these include Tyrant of Discord astral
dragon and trumpet and carnosaur there's
also another key topend creature nezahal
and that one can serve as a gesture to a
key sub theme within this deck flicker
flicker cards perform two functions here
as with the commander they can recycle
ETB creatures and they can also flicker
a creature put out with sneak attack to
keep it around permanently at no
additional expense this gives the deck a
great degree of flexibility in how hard
it wants to commit to the board and in
how much it wants to grind value there's
also a good amount of redundancy in key
types of effect there are four total
cards that can per a sneak attack like
role two enchantments and two non-
enchantment cards that are similar
enough and there are likewise multiple
alternative options for keeping around
sneak attacked creatures outside of the
command Zone overall this is a super
deck great job again filthy Stacks
player next up we have Amber gisto Mall
a four Mana 33 with haste and whenever
this creature attacks you may discard
your hand if you do draw a card for each
player being attacked naturally this
encourages a lot of low slung Scrappy
strategies and this was a commander
where an impressive portion of the decks
were budget decks all of my top picks
here were less than $150 some a lot less
than that as you can see from the plot
here black was a very dominant choice
for a background color among Amber decks
which makes sense given her self-
discard oriented gameplay for a few
honorable mentions we've got a pump
spells Voltron deck a budget aggro deck
and a reanimator deck for the number one
Amber deck though we've got Lord
Reverend's clerics and dwarfes Deck with
haunted one as the partnered background
really this deck focuses on one specific
variety of creature that being clerics
and dwarves that sacrifice creatures to
accomplish tasks we've got 11 of these
along with 12 other clerics and five
other dwarves the basic idea here seems
simple dump these creatures into play
alongside Amber and haunted one and then
swing in with Amber in order to both
wheel and use sacrifice abilities on the
now undying clerics and dwarves this can
produce effects such as destroying a
creature with blind Zealot tutoring out
black creatures with Shadow right priest
and drawing cards with skullport
Merchant the deck also contains five
cards that reanimate in some way
including three attached to a cleric as
well as three Madness cards so there's
some degree of synergy present to work
with Amber's attack trigger her power
and toughness aren't great only 3 three
on a four Mana creature but this doesn't
matter as long as the deck has haunted
one in play this might prompt a
follow-up question what if you want to
sacrifice a creature that already has a
plus one plus1 counter on it the
solution to this potential issue comes
in the form of a handful of cards that
remove counters from creatures there are
nine of these total and while most of
these feel more like filler than
anything else the two enchantments seem
great I sand storm provides a quality
source of repeatable burn damage and
retribution of the Ancients is an even
more potent tool particularly when the
deck's Board gets bigger the other
standout element of this deck is its
Suite of board wipes the deck runs an
eye watering nine board wipes which the
deck can break paradon through haunted
one one of these nine is yako hops which
can provide a game warping nuke once the
pilot of this deck trusts their board to
run to the Finish Line these board wipes
seem like an appropriate tool to help
the deck's honestly mediocre creatures
get around around the large Boards of
modern day EDH decks because that's the
most palpable Vibe this deck gives off
the Jank Factor the cards here are at
best normally mediocre cards being used
in their narrow use case window of being
decent and in some cases mediocre cards
even in this deck we've got late 90s
dwarves various mediocre comons from
across the years Grim wire of the Dead
there's so much nonsense here United in
flavor or function or both this feels
appropriate though for a few reasons
Amber is a fundamentally janky Commander
she's a draw engine but one that
requires playing in a very Scrappy style
and one who doesn't even reward that
style that heavily her two creature
types cleric and dwarf are not generally
great ones to build around clerics have
gotten just enough love to make
shadowborn Apostle decks look Accord of
the way respectable but dwarves yeah no
forget about it in addition this Dex
budget is quite low it's sitting below
the $50 Mark if you exclude haunted one
a card which as Lord Reverend alluded to
is basically free as long as you win
this competition since the prize card is
an altered art version of the card a
wildly polished Deck with top tier card
quality this certainly is not nor was it
intended to be as a final note this deck
also has an undeniable thematic core to
it we have themes of death and dying
riddled throughout this deck including
the haunted one background a whole lot
of cultist type creatures that sacrifice
things to perform rituals and board
wipes that represent great dying off
events lorewise Amber herself is a CL
with connections to the shadow fell
carrying a certain degree of liminality
with her tugged between life and what
lies Beyond this further helps the deck
in communicating itself as a cohesive
unit and the end result has an
undeniable sense of style to it next
let's talk about our white Commander
option Ellen harb's Busy Body she's a
four Mana two4 creature with tap look at
the top X cards of your library where X
is the number of tokens you created this
turn put one of those cards into your
hand and the rest on the bottom of your
library in any order people took this
base in a variety of different
directions but there were two main
patterns one were Decks that create
tokens and also really want a source of
filtering an example of which might be a
combo deck or some sort of synergy
hungry machine sort of deck the other
type of deck people built were decks
specifically interested in maximizing
the level of dig they could get out of
Ellen either through creating a lot of
tokens or by untapping her as you can
see from the pie chart most of the decks
featured either black or green though
this was not the case for our honorable
mentions here these were three blue
white decks a deck built around flyers
and the card mirror weave a haers deck
with a lot of draw denial effects and a
twiddle storm deck built around cards
like towan Sky Summoner however the
winning deck was a different sort of
twiddle storm deck atress 159's bell
ringer Deck with agent of the Iron
Throne chosen as the background this is
a deck focused on effects that untap all
of your creatures four of these untap
all creatures on opposing untap tap
steps eight untap All Creatures once and
a few other cards untap creatures more
selectively to go along with these this
deck has eight creatures that tap to
create a token seven that tap to add
mana and two cards that tap to create
Treasures effectively doing both of
these things once this deck has Ellen
and some of these effects online it can
start to do some cool stuff the deck can
use all tap abilities creating mana and
tokens and filtering and then it can
play a card that untaps all creatures to
refresh all these tappers Mana creat ERS
let the deck avoid running out of Mana
too fast and creating tokens allows the
deck to dig deeper and deeper with Ellen
on each round of tapping hopefully
finding additional untapping effects for
as long as the Ellen player wants to
keep going the deck doesn't have an
explicit wi conon in the 98 outside of
maybe Halo Fountain but the elegant
thing here is that the deck doesn't
really need a specific payoff card for a
big tapping and untapping turn agent of
the iron throne in the command Zone
means that a board full of tokens
already contains an implied level of
damage and several elen activations will
mean a well curated hand of cards when
passing after a big turn to go along
with the rest of this game plan the deck
also contains a handful of one-time
token producers some protection for the
commander and a small Suite of other
support cards what's interesting about
this deck is that I think both agent of
the iron throne and haunted one work
well as backgrounds though they lend
very different play patterns for
finishing off opponents agent of the
Iron Throne gives the deck a more
measured play style that focuses on
optimizing twiddle turns in the moment
and worrying about finishing the game
later once a whole lot of tokens are in
play haunted one on the other hand is
more explosive rewarding careful
planning and avoiding opposing hate with
the potential for some truly disgusting
Alpha strikes either way seems valid to
me though something nice about haunted
one is that it also gives the deck a bit
of something that it's a bit low on at
the moment protection Ellen can tap
herself at any time she's untapped to
Grant the benefit of haunted one even if
no tokens were created during a turn
which gives is a pretty sweet tool for
dealing with removal this is relevant
because the next strategy and its access
to a blood Irish effect depend on Ellen
being in play and Ellen getting single
Target removed can pose a meaningful
setback for the deck this issue is
somewhat counterbalanced though by this
deck's high density of ramp and
inclusion of recovery cards such as
dazzling theater and wand of the world
Soul which can help the deck in getting
Ellen back out to the board rather than
stalling out so this is more of an idea
to play around with than any sort of
major critique overall this deck is
wellb built Dynamic and unique great job
atress
159 next up let's talk about viconia Dr
apostate she's a three Mana 23 whose
text reads at the beginning of your
upkeep if there are four or more
creature cards in your graveyard return
a creature card at random from your
graveyard to your hand on the surface
this card is similar to an enchantment
called oversold Cemetery with one key
distinction The Returned creature is
chosen at random this immediately causes
some problems with the use cases of the
card because if you throw a bunch of
filler creatures into your graveyard
plus a desirable key creature or two
you're probably going to get back
garbage off of viconia or at least
that's the most likely outcome per
trigger naturally there were a mixture
of different solutions players found to
this issue some chose to have most
creatures be functionally identical or
chose Synergy packages where getting
back any creature was beneficial
regardless of what it was from this
chart you can see that the colors were
more spread out with Bonia than with
most of the other commanders though
green was still the most popular for a
few honorable mentions there was an
umori companioned goari mid-range deck a
modular creatures deck and an astral
slide deck for the winning deck we have
a different cycling deck chim's High
Mana value cycling Deck with Tavern
brawler as the background Commander this
was the one- winning deck that 33 elk
Des sented on though they did note that
from a lore standpoint having viconia
drunkenly fighting people is very funny
as you might guess from the description
of the deck I gave the foundation of
this deck lies upon one simple fact
there are a lot of five to six Mana
creatures with some form of cycling or
other this deck contains 13 each of
generic cycling creatures and land
cycling creatures plus an additional
three Channel creatures which can be
discarded for an effect this means that
the deck has a pretty easy time getting
creatures in the graveyard for purposes
of getting vicon's ability online in
addition all of these land cycling
creatures can basically exist in place
of a land so that significantly lowers
the number of lands that need to go in
the deck the other thing that can help
with this is mdfc SE lands at least in
the sense that they allow the deck to
contain more cards whose front side is
not a land this is important for
purposes of Tavern brawler since hitting
a land with the card doesn't buff fonia
as a result of its 13 land cycling
creatures and its 11 mdfc lands the
deck's official land count excluding
mdfc is 14 my manabase tool does rate
this deck's manabase as very strong
after plugging in some appropriate
discounts and I'm inclined to agree with
that analysis though with the caveat
that there will be lands entering tapped
and turn spent land cycling the end
product of this is that the deck has an
exceptionally High average card cost of
4.3 and that's including lands this
means that the deck is likely going to
be able to push a decent amount of
damage with a Tavern brawling Bonia
there are a handful of evasion cards to
help with this as well as a decent Suite
of removal to clear out blockers and
push an opponent into unfavorable blocks
the other thing accomplished by the
command zone is that it contains two
different value engines which can allow
the to maintain a solid Baseline of
gameplay volume even if there are some
setbacks finally the deck has a handful
of other cards which can take advantage
of its high average Mana value in
addition to ton brawler as it stands now
this deck is a funky mid-range battle
cruiser Brew with some fun side paths
however more so than being a perfectly
conceived final deck I like this as a
deck that has a lot of good ideas and
comfortably dips its toes into a lot of
different archetypes a deck whose
elements gesture to a variety of
different directions it could be further
honed more ramp could amplify the battle
cruiser side of it more reanimation
spells could amplify the explosive
creature sheeting side of it more
evasion could amplify the Voltron
elements of this deck more discard or
other resource attacking methods could
amplify the grindy aspects of this deck
and so on it's also very budget at the
moment and it could either be kept that
way or upgraded with a handful of more
powerful cards good stuff finally let's
talk about our green Commander option
hson Emerald Arch Druid is a four Mana
24 with the ability to pay one Mana to
turn a token into a 44 Green Bear until
end of turn this is a great ability in
terms of raw rate like those tokens were
probably something like base power one
one if they were creatures so that's a
plus three plus three for one mana and
if they weren't creatures before that's
a whole different degree of value
however despite having a lot of
potential hson also presents a handful
of questions what tokens should he be
animating and what should be done with a
bunch of for Force there were some
creative answers to these questions
among the submissions as you can see on
this plot blue and white were quite
dominant as the second colors
constituting around a third of decks
each for a few honorable mentions there
was a deck that animated oras to
generate sack triggers off of MERS Bond
a power Stones deck and a tokens
enchantress deck that used opal lessons
to get an additional copy of the
background bonus for the winning deck we
have QB ccl's incubate Deck with
inspiring leader used as the background
incubate is an unusual mechanic
introduced in March of the machine that
creates artifact tokens with plus one
plus1 counters on them and these tokens
Can later be transformed into z00
creatures for two Mana this has some
very clear upsides paired with Hon
ability for one we get all the benefits
of the plus one plus1 counters on the
tokens without needing to pay the two
Mana to flip them instead paying one
Mana to get them for a turn with an
additional plus4 plus4 on top secondly
the fact that these tokens don't need to
be flipped makes them more resilient
instead of exploding to either an
artifact wipe or a creature wipe these
tokens will generally die only to
artifact wipes since they're typically
not creatures on our opponent's turns
they also don't even have to be
creatures on our turn this deck runs a
number of board wipes which have the
potential to be kind of one-sided with
the deck storing power and toughness in
its incubate tokens the deck contains 12
total cards that create incubator tokens
and with their relative permanence in
mind it also runs a number of cards that
can proliferate the plus one plus1
counters on them gradually ramping up
the size of these tokens turn over turn
there are also eight other cards in the
deck that use counters in some way which
is good as it means that the proliferate
cards are going to be getting value
outside of the incubators which is good
as there aren't that many of them due to
them only being in one set likewise many
of these cars that use counters also
create tokens with this deck containing
a total of 17 other token creating cards
outside of the incubate cards which is
good as the deck's main plan for winning
is animating things with hson and
swinging in with them the background is
here to amplify that plan boosting the
four four Bears up to 66 Bears this buff
might be less meaningful in contexts
with an especially large number of
tokens but when the deck only has a
handful of tokens to swing in with that
size difference can be quite relevant to
the outcome of the combat as I alluded
to earlier this deck has seven board
wipes which further enhance its combat
potential while the commander isn't
likely to survive a wipe the incubate
tokens usually will which can allow for
a nice swing on a following turn or I
suppose the same turn if the deck has a
lot of Mana at that moment overall this
deck is a well-rounded mid-range deck
based around a not very heavily played
mechanic that goes excellently with Alon
love to see it all right those were the
winning decks I appreciate everybody who
participated as even though it took a
while to go through all the submissions
it's always super fun to see what people
come up with you can check out the
honorable mentions in the link down in
the description and you can also feel
free to let me know in the comments what
you thought of these decks what was your
favorite was there a deck I didn't pick
that you think was terribly robbed you
can also let me know if you have ideas
for future deck building challenges
because these are fun and I'll probably
do two to three more later this year
with that said thanks for watching and
thanks to my patrons for supporting my
work on this channel if you want to join
them a link to my patreon is down in the
description and I greatly appreciate the
generosity of all those who contribute
all right that's all for this one bye